from a Hollywood version of an iconic
training scene to a new name on some
famous boxing shorts Creed 3 is chock
full of small details that bring the
entire Rocky Cinematic Universe full
circle in the first Creed movie Adonis
or Dani is torn between wanting to make
a name for himself all on his own and
using Apollo Creed's Legacy as a
springboard for his own career after
being deemed untrainable at every turn
he moves from Los Angeles to
Philadelphia to train with his father's
friend and formal rival Rocky Balboa as
Rocky trains a young Creed Donnie
becomes a powerful force to be reckoned
with following in both Rocky and
Apollo's footsteps by the time Dani
finally steps into the ring to face
Pretty Ricky conlon Hollywood Adonis
Johnson trades his biological mother's
name for his father's and reintroduces
himself to the boxing world as Adonis
Creed in honor of his past Donny Sports
the Johnson name on the back of his red
white and blue boxing shorts with Creed
displayed prominently on the front as to
not forget where it came from this
remains consistent throughout all of
Creek 2 also taking place years after
the second installment when we catch up
with Adonis at the start of Creed 3 he's
completely shed the Johnson name and
identity in favor of the Creed title and
Legacy his new red shorts signify that
Donnie has finally come to terms with
who he is and where he comes from Creed
3 opens with a flashback to Donny's
childhood spent with his best friend and
older brother figure Dame Anderson the
past came back too after infiltrating a
boxing underground ring Donnie and Dame
head back home only to get in trouble
along the way but before Donny picks a
fight with the abusive man who ran the
role group home it gives Dame something
from his father's Personal Collection a
Rumble in the Jungle ticket on the
surface there is nothing incredibly
special about this other than it came
from Apollo Creed himself but fans may
remember what makes the event in
question so special in Creed 2 promoter
buddy Marcel mentions that a battle
between Dani and Victor Draco would be
as big as Rumble in the Jungle though
the fight between the sons of creed and
Drago was a long time coming it's the
battle between Creed and Anderson that's
most like the actual event no doubt the
battle for Los Angeles at the end of
Crete 3 serves as Donny's own Rumble in
the Jungle cementing him as the best of
his generation
in the original Rocky movies Rocky
Balboa duked it out with Apollo Creed
twice before the pair became good
friends by the time Rocky III came
around these two-time Rivals were as
thick as thieves so after Apollo died in
the ring and Rocky IV the Italian
Stallion took on his killer Ivan Drago
for a personal Vendetta if anything the
rocky films know how to bring back
former antagonists with a new twist
Creed 2 which was co-written by
Sylvester Stallone brought back Drago
portraying the villain in a more
sympathetic light well just like the
rocky films before the Creed series
honors its past by bringing back Donny's
old enemies from the ring in Creed's
final retirement fight at the start of
the film he's once again pitted against
Pretty Ricky conlon though this time he
beats Conlan claiming the heavyweight
title is his own but Conlan isn't the
only old opponent of Donny's to show up
in Crete 3. Victor Drago returns as well
this time is Donny's friend rather than
his enemy odani's attempts to set up a
fight between the younger Drago and
Starfighter Felix Chavez are thwarted by
Dame the younger Creed and Drago
remained friends evidently Time Heals
all wounds aside from a passing
reference in the first Creed the other
children of Apollo Creed and unnamed son
and daughter are rarely mentioned though
they appeared briefly in Rocky II
running away from their frustrated
mother Apollo's other children haven't
shown up again in any installment of the
rocky franchise even after Apollo Creed
died in Rocky IV
you guys he dies since Adonis was born
shortly after Apollo's death the former
Master of Disaster never knew he had an
illegitimate son because of this it took
Mary Ann Crete years to track Donnie
down before adopting him as her own for
years the question of how they might
have responded to having a new sibling
was a question we never thought would be
answered Creed 3 changes this with a
powerful and heartbreaking moment in
which Adonis reminds his adoptive mother
that his half-siblings never fully
accepted him as their brother while Dame
did of all their Creed kids Adonis is
arguably the closest to his mother and
since Marianne took a special liking to
Dani from a young age it's obvious why
his older siblings might not have taken
too kindly to another Creed in the house
Donnie going by the surname Johnson
probably didn't help things much either
even at Marianne's funeral her other
children don't seem to show up and if
they do the film doesn't take any time
to highlight their appearance still at
least we know they haven't been
completely forgotten after Diamond Dame
Anderson wins a heavyweight title Donnie
confronts his old friend about his
violent behavior and Shady tactics in
the ring unfortunately this conversation
doesn't quite go as planned and Donnie
is ridiculed and even beaten by his
former pal who threatens to take
everything he has but there's one insult
that Dame hurls at Donnie that the prize
fighter can't stand baby Creed when the
news at Adonis Johnson was actually
Apollo Crete's son broke out in the
first Creed it was without Donnie's
involvement both he and Rocky were
blindsided by the media league but they
quickly overcame it and used it to their
advantage Lani moved past the Johnson
name taking the Creed title for his own
and fighting tooth and nail to rise to
the top of course with the Creed name
came distinct challenges namely the
direct tie to his father's Legacy in the
Imposter syndrome that spawned from it
in the first Creed when he's called Baby
Creed by the headliner at Bianca's
performance Donnie loses his temper and
nearly beats the guy up but by the time
Dame calls him the same thing in Crete 3
Donny's restraint shows just how much
he's grown and the fighting isn't about
some Childish need to prove himself
worthy of the Creed name any longer it's
no secret that Sylvester Stallone didn't
return as Rocky Balboa for creed 3.
despite remaining on as a producer after
some serious feuds with longtime Rocky
producer Irwin Winkler the star claimed
that there wasn't much room in the flick
for him anyway well it's mostly true the
character's Legacy is still a vibrant
part of creed 3. now it doesn't get many
mentions but after a send-off in Crete 2
Rocky seems to have made peace with
boxing rather instead of calling up his
old Mentor for advice on how to deal
with Dame Adonis decides to take Rocky's
teachings to Heart applying them
Faithfully to his fighting style and
rigorous training techniques during the
unorthodox nature of his training
montage Dani remembers one of his unk's
most important lessons that no matter
who he's fighting his toughest opponent
will always be himself near the end of
his training montage Donnie is seen
sparring on a Runway with no one around
for miles and the only thing with him is
a giant mirror this gives him a full
view of himself and his surroundings as
he studies his own technique Rocky's
wisdom continues to bless Adonis as he
goes into the battle for Los Angeles
hoping to secure his victory
though he was born and raised in Los
Angeles Adonis Creed didn't become a
household name until after he'd moved to
Philly trained with Rocky and fully
embraced the Creed Legacy after becoming
a champion and starting a family Donnie
relocated across the country back to LA
to be closer to his mom able to afford a
new life of luxury the Creed family
embraced the Southern California
lifestyle with ease Creed 3 even takes
the time to further explore their life
in La namely through their relationship
with their daughter as Adonis trains to
reclaim his heavyweight title from Dame
he follows Rocky's unorthodox training
techniques and the advice of his
longtime trainer Tony Little Duke Evers
though he put his own spin on Rocky's
famous climb up the steps of the
Philadelphia Museum of Arts and Creed
Adonis carves his own path forward in
Creed 3 replacing the iconic steps with
the hilltop above the Hollywood Sign
while this is no doubt to nod to Rocky's
steps it's also a reflection of where
Don came from when he first began his
career as a fighter the young Creed was
originally known as Hollywood Adonis
Johnson as he climbs toward the
Hollywood Sign Dani proves that he's
made peace with his past before stepping
back into the ring to take back what's
rightfully his own it might not be as
iconic as Rockies climb but it's just as
meaningful during the title fight
between Creed and diamond and Dame share
a brief moment in the ring where they
each slug the other right in the face
this epic shot reminds us that these two
are possibly the most evenly matched
fighters in the Rocky verse and while
plenty of others have duped it out in
the ring few fights are as personal as
this one but this moment is also a nod
to another fight one that we didn't even
see unfold on screen at the end of Rocky
3 Rocky and Apollo decided to learn once
and for all who is the better fighter
you fight great but I'm a great fighter
huh you ready
well absolutely after Apollo 1 and Rocky
and Rocky Run in the sequel these two
needed to settle the score once and for
all unlike most fights it took over 30
years before a winner was announced as
Rocky eventually told Adonis that his
father won parents Square so what does
this have to do with that shot from
Creed 3 over starters Rocky 3 ends with
a freeze frame that catches Rocky and
Apollo socking the other clean in the
jaw yes the fight between these two
happened behind closed doors while
Donnie and Dame's battle was broadcast
internationally but Creed 3 actually
isolates Creed Anderson with no outside
interference in the middle of the fight
Adonis only sees himself in Dame as his
two brothers settle their differences
the old-fashioned way not unlike the end
of Rocky III but that's not the only
significance that the punch holds
Michael B Jordan's been outspoken about
his love for anime and how it influenced
the visual style of his directorial
debut that includes dropping a few
direct references to his favorite anime
the cross punch calls back to Naruto
while the painful looking gut punch
featured in the trailer is a Dragon Ball
Z reference a huge theme throughout the
Creed Trilogy is that of making a name
for yourself everestani is afraid of the
Apollo Creed comparisons then he
Embraces the name honoring both the
Johnson title and Apollo's own legacy
but by the third Act of Creed 3 he's
moved on past honoring his Johnson name
and even puts the Creed name itself on
the back burner in his comeback match
against Diamond Dame Anderson Adonna
supports a new pair of fighting shorts
these ones white with the name Adonis on
the front and Creed on the back for
eight years Dania spent much of his time
as a fighter working out his own issues
without a dad but after becoming a
father himself Adonis has decided that
making something of his own name rather
than just his fathers is his new
priority his brand new fighting shorts
are a reflection of that but they aren't
the only one we're also reintroduced to
Apollo's old gym the Delphi boxing
Academy now run by Donnie himself the
whole Jam has been redesigned and not
only honors Apollo's past but adonis's
presence while preparing new Fighters
for the future even Donny's new company
name Adonis Creed Athletics proudly
Sports an a-shaped logo with a small C
in the center again emphasizing his
Newfound commitment to his own name in
Legacy no doubt Creed 3 proves that
Adonis Creed is a name that won't be
taken lightly going forward
[Music]
foreign